[Music]
my name is Lisa cosu I'm the owner of
Shiki New York City
I make dental boxes for Mahuta I was
born in Tokyo and I want to bring the
culture of bento box to New York there
are so many nutrition's he said one box
white lies and vegetable meat fish and a
sometimes of fruits I think that's very
important obey the books to make more
variety it takes so much time to prepare
to make him better boxes it takes 5
hours to prep one day before
I always try to put maybe six or seven
dishes inside one box and seven courses
must be very well balanced
[Music]
some dishes is sweet somebody she's a
spicy and some dishes are SOT pentapox
is a kind of art this is so small very
very tiny it's so fun to make nicer I
always take so much time to put nicely
prettier but it's not just presentation
presentation is very important but in
topics must be healthy and must be well
balanced
in Japan bento box was mainly for kids
so their mom how did you make bento box
almost every money
my mom made bento box everyday when I
was a student I was looking forward to
having my mom's bento box every day I
always could be very happy with that
bento box means a kind of a happy moment
for me this is what I want to bring to
people here this feeling I think this is
the purpose that I want to make bento
box making bento box sounds a little bit
complicated and a so troublesome but
it's not because there's no rule I'm
making my stuff in a box but people can
make their own stuff vent about I want
people in America to have fun with and
making bento box and enjoy bento box
[Music]